[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans ce premier numéro de paf
2021 et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
vous souhaiter une très belle année en
dont on espère qu'elle sera plus plus
positive que celle qui vient de se clore
à priori elle ne devrait pas avoir de
mal mais c'est tout jamais elle a
d'ailleurs commencé de manière assez
contrasté avec l'invasion du capital aux
états unis mercredi dernier invasion qui
a nous a montré une démocratie fragilisé
peut être abîmée et puis en france
l'espoir qu'a fait m la découverte du
vaccin contre la corrida était vite
refroidis par les retards et difficultés
de la mise en oeuvre de la vaccination
la démocratie fragiliser le retard dans
les vaccins sont deux des principaux
thèmes que nous allons aborder
aujourd'hui avec alexandra rosetti
bonjour vous êtes la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous êtes la
vice-présidente aussi de saint quentin
en yvelines sur le sur le plateau
laurent basauri bonjour bonne année à
toutes et à tous une bonne année et vous
êtes adjoint au maire d'elancourt est
aussi vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines et président aussi de de tv 78
et puis avec nous en visio et me porter
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes la plus
célèbre des américaines des yvelines
c'est ce que vous êtes la porte parole
du parti démocrate et on a envie de vous
entendre sur ce qui s'est passé mercredi
aux états unis
une jean baptiste florence mercadé souk
et bonjour vous êtes au barreau de
versailles jean baptiste duclair bonjour
maître de conférences à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin spécialiste de
droit public et donc on va
ça va être intéressant de vous entendre
justement sur la bureaucratie dont on a
l'impression qu'elle règne en maître en
france vincent couronne également vous
êtes juriste en droit vous êtes le
fondateur des surligneurs qui traquait
les facs news notamment dans le domaine
politique
et puis jean charles lajoie ni bonjour
vous êtes éditeur
bonjour à tous bonjour alors on va
commencer par ce qui s'est passé aux
etats-unis cette démocratie abîmées
[Musique]
alors résonner une mercredi avait
commencé avec une bonne nouvelle pour
les démocrates c'est à dire l'élection
géorgie de deux sénateurs qui permet au
parti démocrate et joe biden d'avoir la
majorité au sénat en tout cas il y aura
les sénateurs de chaque côté mais comme
la vice présidente aura une voix
prépondérante
il aura donc la majorité et puis il ya
eu cette invasion des du capitole vous
avez regardé à la télévision ce qui
s'est passé vous ça vous à quoi sidérer
étonné choqué alexandre oui oui ça m'a
choqué bah oui absolument ça moi j'étais
j'étais extrêmement étonné de la
facilité apparente en tout cas avec
laquelle ils sont rentrés dans ce sac
romsa a lieu quand même assez semblable
à lui même
faudra quand même eu quatre morts si
vous n'êtes pas c'est pas rien fait ou 5
voilà bon nombre donc cesser absolument
moi j'étais atterré effectivement
intérêt cgt évidemment comme tous les
français et comme alexandra ici choqué
en même temps je me dis également que ça
nous renvoie notre propre image et que
ce risque existe aujourd'hui
potentiellement france être intéressant
de oui voilà on va commencer par ce qui
s'est passé aux états dit mais ça va
être intéressant de savoir si massa
pourrait se produire en europe en france
notamment et me porter bon set c'était
une cérémonie a priori formelle où on
annonçait les résultats du scrutin donc
l'élection de joe biden trump avait
depuis longtemps dit que ça ne se
passerait pas comme ça il a exhorté
d'ailleurs dans un discours ses
partisans à venir jusqu'au capitole
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est lui qui
porte la responsabilité de ce qui s'est
passé
bien sûr il porte une grande part de
responsabilité il n'est pas le seul
il y a eu pas mal d'autres législateurs
qui dans son sillon qui l'ont renforcé
sur tout et ont continué à mentir même
deux mois après cette élection qui a été
qualifié par l'administration tremblay
elle même d'élection la plus réglo de
notre histoire
donc ils ont comment continuer à mentir
pendant deux mois en disant s'il y avait
de la fraude on m'a volé l'élection et
saissac et inciter tous ces gens qui
croient vraiment à cette mensonge à ce
mensonge et après ben il les a incités à
la céruse insurrection c'est exactement
le l'article de pitch bend qui va être
annoncé
je parle demain ou mercredi incitations
à l'insurrection
justement cette procédure d'impeachment
oui certains démocrates et sert même
certains républicains sûr ils sont
favorables
est ce que c'est un intérêt alors que
trump a quitté le pouvoir le 20 janvier
et qu'il a assuré qu'il le ferait il va
quitter le pouvoir le 20 janvier ça
c'est certain mais on a tous vu qu'il
est capable de faire alors qu'est-ce qui
est capable de faire dans les neuf
joueurs qui restent je veux même pas y
penser
en fait on va procéder par étapes
l'impeachment sera la dernière étape
si vous avez bien regardé ce qu'a dit
madame nancy pelosi ya soir à 6 10
minutes
elle a dit que d'abord elle demande à ce
que trump démissionne chose qu'il ne
fera pas parce que dans sa tête il n'a
rien fait de mal
donc il ne démissionnera pas après nous
avons le 25e amendement qui permet dans
le cas de l'incapacité d'un président de
le sortir de son rôle est de le
remplacer temporairement par le vice
président ça c'est le vice président
mike pence qui doit invoquer ce 25e
amendement il a déjà dit qu'il ne fera
pas en dépit du fait que cette émeute au
capital mercredi appelées à ce qu'il
soit pendu le vice-président donc très
bien si il n'y a pas d'émission s'il ya
pas 25e amendement après la chambre tra
les articles d'une mutuelle qui est un
peu comme une inculpation
après ça passe au sénat où il aura lieu
le procès à proprement dit et beaucoup
de gens commencent à dire c'est
peut-être pas une si bonne idée que ça
parce que une fois que les articles d'un
petit cheval sont transmis au sénat
le sénat doit arrêter tout ce qui fait
et ne faire que ça ne s'occuper que de
ça alors si la présidence de joe byden
démarre avec un ami tu mènes danse dit
c'est peut-être parce qu'il ya mieux
il a d'autres chats à fouetter il a
beaucoup de choses à mettre en place
avec son nouveau programme donc
veux-t-on les articles de budget mais on
les envoie pas tout de suite c'est l'un
on va les garder comme ça dans
l'histoire ça à noter que tremper le
seul président avoir été destituée enfin
beach deux fois pape en entendant un
seul mandat
en sachant que on pourra attendre les
100 premiers jours de baden avant de
transmettre le tribunal
et oui les experts juridiques moi j'ai
consulté m'indique qu'on peut tout à
fait se tenir le procès pour un pitch
mène d'un président qui est déjà sortie
du mandat mais alors est-ce que c'est
pas parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
républicains du parti dont de 30 qu'ils
disent au fond cette procédure
d'impeachment c'est une façon justement
de
ruiné la carrière de trump de quelqu'un
qui a quand même pour le pour lequel
pardon 76 millions de dhs américains ont
quand même voté après ce qui s'est passé
mercredi
personnellement je ne vois pas comment
une seule personne qu'ils soient
républicains et démocrates puissent
désirer ce personnage monte à nouveau
dans une position de responsabilité
la procédure d'impeachment lui même ne
donne pas d'inéligibilité à train mais
permet un vote dans une autre résolution
pour l'empêcher de se représenter à
quelques mandats que ce soit je ne sais
pas si en france en mesure la gravité de
ce qui s'est passé mercredi
quand vous parlez avec des américains il
dit j'ai l'impression
c'est encore le 9 septembre que c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment frapper
au coeur de notre comme dubaï de lui
même a dit qui a frappé le citadelle de
la démocratie les gens sont traumatisés
et ils veulent que il y est je dirais
pas punition mais que quelqu'un soit
tenu deux responsables on ne peut pas
juste passé en disant bon il sera parti
dans 18 ans va rien faire
ils ont déjà fait ça avec l'inpi chase
il ya un an en disant vous avez vu il a
compris la leçon il ne fera rien de mal
et regardons nous sommes maintenant donc
même si c'est symbolique
les démocrates concept cette idée cette
notion ce sentiment en qu'il faille
vraiment que quelqu'un soit tenu pour
responsable de ce qui s'est passé c'est
une tragédie et c'est une asso à la
démocratie américaine ces gens là
voulaient empêcher les résultats d'une
élection dûment tenu à être mise en mise
en place et s'est dit qu'on vous dit
personne ne veut le revoir au pouvoir
jeu là c'est quand même la représentante
du parti démocrate rassemble des clubs
parce que j'ai pas sûr que personne aux
états unis
2 ne soutiennent trop voulait réagir
dans ce que dit aimer porter non mais
tout ça tout ça ne me paraît pas très
démocratique de vouloir soi-disant
réconcilier les états unis en se disant
bien pour réconcilier les états unis
pour ce pour que tout s'arrange on va
aller jusqu'au bout interdire un
président qui a été élu pas volé sa
victoire 2 possiblement se représenter
on lui coupe son coût son compte twitter
enfin je veux dire en evans dans une
vision de la démocratie qui n'est pas du
tout la vienne quoi je ne comprends pas
du tout cette façon de dire on va
l'empêcher de pouvoir se représenter je
veux dire qu'on lui fasse que vous lui
fassiez un procès certes si vous pensez
qu'il ya de quoi faire un procès qu'il
soit jugé mais mes pattes pas de vote
qui interdirait à quelqu'un de se
présenter comme quelqu'un qui soit ceux
plus de près de 80 millions de dhs
électeurs ont voté pour lui et c'est
voilà ça me paraît totalement aberrant
est vraiment d'une vision de la
démocratie pour le moins curieuse et à
géométrie variable
les syndicats parlent mais juste pour
dire que je pense que ça va venir
alimenter sa ca martyrologie que c'est
très bon pour lui parce que ça en fait
je pense que c'est ce qu'il cherchait
spécialistes mais de manière générique
de toute façon ils font partie des
dictateurs vient de pouvoir aussi par le
résultat démocratique et il est toujours
compliqué c'est ce que l'allemagne en
trombe en allemagne je pense à l'algérie
avec la venue au pouvoir des extrémistes
mais pour autant cela ne doit pas
légitimer une forme d intelligence ya
supérieur qui viendraient effectivement
employés différentes solutions pour dire
qui peut se présenter une élection qui
ne peut pas et qui en gros quand il est
élu par le peuple néanmoins ne n'est pas
habilité elle représentait il ou 79
millions d'américains je dire c'est loin
d'être peu c'est certainement pas cette
bande d'abrutis qui ont été prendre
d'assaut parce que c'est leur mot et
c'est comme ça qu'il faut et caractérisé
d'ailleurs sonné meurtrier même
aujourd'hui prendre la seule capitale
mais néanmoins il reste quand même
détenteur d'un élan qui n'était pas loin
d'être majoritaires et deux fois de
suite
alors après que le résultat de la
démarche arrive à une lisibilité par une
décision qui de fait sera démocratique
parce qu'elle sera
dans le respect du droit c'est une chose
mais que ce soit pas un objectif en tant
que tel ce qui pose problème c'est de
dire aux va lancer cette opération là
pour arriver à son éligibilité
non s'il le devient parce qu'il est jugé
ça sera effectivement démocratique mais
ça peut pas être un objectif et là je
rejoins jean rejoint effectivement et
alexandra et jean charles ça peut pas
être un objectif
pris comme tel ou alors ça veut dire que
la démocratie ne se fait plus dans les
urnes elle se fait dans les tribunaux on
l'a connu récemment en france
c'est un vrai et qui à ce moment là peut
considérer qu'il représente en tant que
tel lui même tout seul la tête et et des
électeurs américains personnes et les
pères fondateurs n'aurait pas voulu
d'ailleurs on pourrait parler peut-être
que notre notre collègue démocrate
pourrait nous dire pourquoi les pères
fondateurs ont voulu un sénat à parité
au potentiellement chiffres pairs qui
nous arrive à cette situation si elle
est en effet bien c'est 50-50 tranchée
par le vice-président fin au jeu je
connais un peu le sujet on pourra en
parler mais c'est quand même également
un point problématique qui quelque part
attisent aussi le fait qu'elle sorte de
gens considèrent que le vote leur est
volée qui n'ont pas suffrages déjà que
c'est indirect mais qui en plus arrivent
dans des situations parfois de blocage
avec deux sénateurs par et à quelle que
soit l'importance exactement l'état jean
baptiste duclair sur sur ces événements
évidemment ça pose un problème
les etats unis c'est on dit que c'est la
plus grande démocratie moderne du monde
est ce que ça ne montre pas au fond de
la faiblesse peut-être des de nos
démocraties on a l'impression que les
démocraties sont inattaquables
et au fond elles le sont peut-être pas
autant que ça oui alors on déjà le
grandes démocraties en parlant des états
unis par la taille peut être pas par le
modèle politique moi j'ai une admiration
sans bornes le modèle britannique que le
trouble le modèle démocratique le plus
abouti si je puis dire à la barre du
modèle américain
alors oui effectivement c'est un un
danger évident pour la démocratie de
voir le parlement pris d'assaut par des
quelques énergumènes du type délit
croquettes
personne c'est un danger certain encore
que ce danger par et met en perspective
avec la manière dont justement les
services ont été mis en place à ces
mineurs parce que ce qu'on peut d'abord
critiqué cela était indiqué tout à
l'heure c'est que les services de police
n'était pas suffisant pour contrer cette
menace alors même que comme on l'imaginé
services de renseignement étaient je
pense suffisamment au clair sur la
question devant savoir qu' un tel
mouvement on pouvait arriver
alors cela tient probablement aussi à la
difficulté qu'il ya entre les services
de police du capitole du congrès mais
pia évidemment probablement probablement
à revoir
alors après quand on parle d' atteinte à
la démocratie je crois qu'il faut qu'il
ne faut pas l'inclure dans l'outrance et
dans l'exagération parce que ces
personnes qui ont envahi le capitole
sont absolument convaincus dans leurs
démarches n'ont pas de pouvoir
substituer la démocratie par un régime
autoritaire ou totalitaires et de
vouloir rétablir la démocratie parce que
selon eux c'est le résultat justement de
l'élection qui n'a pas été correct qui
n'a pas été conforme à la réalité il n'y
avait aucune critique en fait des
résultats électoraux
alors qui n'est pas fondée ainsi on a
foi dans dans la décision qui a été
prise par suprême et par par l'ensemble
des magistrats
mais ce qu'il faut quand même comprendre
c'est que ces gens-là sont convaincus
que probablement à ce que manipuler
parce que notamment par les réseaux
sociaux par cette espèce d'hystérie qui
s'y joue mais ces gens là sont
convaincus que c'est la démocratie qui
est attaqué c'est la raison pour
laquelle il souhaitait justement
intervenir
hall a rétabli sa crème important de le
signaler parce que voilà on n'est pas
dans une logique complètement en q2 de
guérilla qui qui voudraient faire qu on
rétablissait la façon docteur 17 une
espèce de dictature udd séquelles pour
les terriens mérite ça c'est très
important à comprendre mais c'est vrai
mais est ce que au fond le danger que
court no2 mocratie les démocraties le
plus ancien c'est pas le coup d'état par
un dictateur je crois que ça personne
n'y croit trop mais c'est peut-être là
perte de nos valeurs démocratiques une
sorte de déliquescence quoi presque
invisible mais qui ce qui se joue à
chaque moment
ben sedrine baptiste est ce qui n'a pas
été un peu gênant aussi que tous les
médias
un peu comme le fait et me d'ailleurs
nous disent l'élection n'a eu aucun
souci c'est la meilleure élections de
tous les temps terre depuis la nuit des
temps
à chaque élection d'un président
américain il ya effectivement des
endroits où ça se passe pas si bien que
ça et c'est à peu près normale et là
comme par hasard tout d'un coup tout le
monde avait tellement envie que 3 me
soit battu qu'on a balayé toutes les
objections te dis mais n'en de 13 ans
y'a même pas une voix qui a été mal
content et c'est donc il ya aussi eu un
sentiment sûrement de la part du de
certains électeurs républicains qui sont
dit mais on est vraiment en train de
prendre pour des abrutis
comment penser que pas un seul butin n'a
été mal compté c'est une opération en
fumant magique c'est de saint-esprit qui
est descendue cette élection est donc ça
les médias extrêmement responsable
d'avoir tellement joli d'avoir tellement
été dans le camp anti en titre up date
d'avoir pendant des pendant des mois dit
qu'il serait battu qui serait que ce
serait ridicule
après sony mais non mais il n'y a pas la
moindre pas la moindre faute lien comme
une absence de prise en compte de la
réalité qui a pu aussi ça n'excuse pas
m'aimer mais qui peut quand même
expliqué que gère que certains
républicains et certains trump heist
parce qu'il faut pas confondre trump
heist est républicain je pense se soit
senti un petit peu un petit peu floués
par cette opération mais reconnaît il il
ya eu 63 euros fait entre le 3 novembre
et aujourd'hui 63 fois l'équipe trump
est allé au tribunal ils ont eu ce 0-0
preuves de fraudes
je ne vous dis pas qu'ils avaient pas un
bulletin ou deux qui a été qui a causé
problème est d'ailleurs on a trouvé deux
personnes en pennsylvanie qui ont tenté
de vote et votera pour leur maman qui
était décédé donc il y a eu quelques
erreurs
ce que je vous dis c'est qu'il faille
fraudes massives et se trouve à dix
depuis même avant l'élection des angles
je ne peux perdre aussi ses trucs et il
a mis ça dans la tête des gens et encore
mercredi après que le capitole a été
rétablie et que les législateurs en
revenus pour voter l'élection il y avait
été creusée josh ans les deux sénateurs
qui ont continué à dire
nous pensons qu'il ya eu faute parce
qu'il y a allégations de fraude
je suis pas avocat mais on ne va pas au
tribunal avec des allégations
on est 20 avec des preuves il n'y a
aucune preuve donc arrêtons de dire que
oui peut-être qu'il ya eu problème
il n'y a pas eu fraude massive dans
cette élection fois les tribunaux y
compris un tas de juges de juges qui ont
été nommé par preuve on dit sur
tellement tribunal vous l'avez aucune
preuve
oui c'est vrai que tous les recours ont
été rejetés
florence père cadets vincent compte
justement si on élargit un peu en fin
séance heures de la situation purement
américaine est ce que est ce que cet
épisode ne peut nous faire dire que les
démocraties sont plus fragiles qu'on ne
le pensait
écoutez moi je suis jeune je ne pense
pas parce que la démocratie aux états
unis sort plutôt vainqueur dès lors qu'
il ya eu il ya des actions qui ont été
faites les périodes people à 500 puisque
à peine cinq mois a suffisamment ces
sept personnes ont été arrêtées pour
être jugé c'est pour ça que je pense que
le fait de poursuivre
trump en une pichenette est parfaitement
légitime puisque c'est lui qui a incité
à l'insurrection
donc il n'y avait pas de raison que ce
soit le seul à ne pas être jugé dans
cette affaire
et s'agissant de nos démocraties à nous
parce que c'est quand même relativement
solide lorsqu'on faudrait se souvenir
que les gilets jaunes avaient a tenté de
prendre d'assaut
l'assemblée nationale avait aussi un
ministère souvient pour lequel il avait
été arrêté
et je pense que la démocratie va sortir
renforcée et j'espère qu'elle sera
renforcée aux états unis
de par ces événements et c'est tout
voilà je peux pas d'accord avec jean
charles lima belge jean baptiste ont-ils
dit le cantique ces personnes-là avait
des raisons légitimes prendre des soldes
[Musique]
mais je n'ai jamais dit qu'il y avait là
on va se déplacer bien le cas des états
unis excusez moi vincent couronne
vincent couronne justement il ya quand
même de deux 2 2 c'est vraiment je ne
peux pas laisser dire ça je n'ai
absolument pas parler de raison légitime
j'ai expliqué l'état d'esprit dans
lequel se greffent les personnes qui ont
envahi le capitole et selon eux il
considère que les résultats sont faussés
je ne dis pas qu'ils en raison je pense
qu'ils ont tort mais c'est simplement
pour expliquer que l'on ne voulait pas
faire une tentative de coup d'état mais
que s'emploie on voulait un régime
démocratique à partir de considérations
qui sont fausses par rapport aux
résultats électoraux c'est pas du tout
la même chose
oui mais c'était c'était franchement un
coup d'état qu'il voulait alors j'ai
peut être mal compris ce que vous avez
dit la raison des ddd gens qui sautent
qui ont envie de capitaux vingt cinq ans
il ya quand même deux choses assez
importante et je voudrais qu'on parle un
peu de la france parce que ça peut venir
ici c'est d'abord cette qu'on appelle la
poste vérité c'est dire que de
considérer qu' il n'y a pas de vérité il
n'y a pas de mensonge avec des opinions
et puis c'est la force des réseaux
sociaux aussi se dire que c'est une
force virtuel au départ de de n1 peu
sûres sur les réseaux sociaux qui se
regroupent qui devient réel en allant au
capitole est-ce que ça c'est pas des
dangers et les et la poste vérité et
l'influencé des réseaux sociaux qui
menace qui peuvent le passé toutes les
démocraties
en france aussi en europe aussi écouté
patrice ce qui est certain c'est que cet
événement a été vraiment une onde de
choc mondiale
et me porter parler de tout à l'heure de
faisait une référence au 11 septembre
en réalité des des spécialistes du
numérique disent que le 11 septembre il
a eu lieu sur le numérique et sur les
réseaux sociaux lorsque trump a été
suspendu de facebook de twitter et que
ces différentes que différentes
plateformes comme parleurs qui sont des
plateformes ultra conservatrice et
d'extrême droite on est exclu certains
hébergeurs pourquoi est-ce que cet
événement il est il est considérable et
bien tout simplement parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on considère que les
plateformes compte twitter facebook sont
des hébergeurs c'est à dire qu'ils ne
sont pas responsables du contenu qui est
publié chez eux un petit peu comme une
bibliothèque ou en kiosque à journaux
sauf que à partir du moment où ces
plateformes commence à modérer les
contenus à exclure certaines personnes
notamment des personnalités politiques
eh bien ils peuvent être considéré de
plus en plus comme des éditeurs c'est à
dire qu'ils établissent une vraie ligne
éditoriale font des choix éditoriaux sur
les contenus et par conséquent être
responsable de ce que de ce qui les
publie sur les réseaux sociaux
le lien avec la postérité il est tout à
fait il est très clair simplement parce
que aux états unis il y à ce qu'on
appelle la section de 130 qui est une
loi en fait qui justement dégage
coûterait 2 les hébergeurs de toute
responsabilité de ce qui est publié sur
les réseaux sociaux et bien il y a
actuellement un projet de cette loi pour
mieux les responsabiliser et cette
réforme
actuellement les sur le bureau de maire
est du coup sûr le bureau de joe biden
ça va être un de ses seins de ses grands
chantiers en europe on a il ya quelques
semaines une proposition il a eu il ya
quelques semaines une proposition de la
commission européenne pour justement
responsabiliser ce qu'on appelle la loi
sur les services numériques
responsabiliser les réseaux sociaux et
toutes ces plateformes sur leur contenu
donc en fait qui est en train de se ré
se passait réellement
c'est que on est en train de
lever cette naïveté qu'on avait
jusque-là de considérer que les réseaux
sociaux étaient toutes à totalement
neutre dans la circulation des
informations
mais qu au contraire en fait ils ont un
réel rôle dans la diffusion des faits
qui use là des informations générales
n'oublions pas que donald trump a
lui-même déclaré que s'il a été élu
c'était grâce à twitter
est ce que justement vous êtes maire de
vos arbres autour d'eux est ce que vous
avez à faire aux réseaux sociaux est ce
que vous il ya beaucoup de réactions sur
les réseaux sociaux x ça change votre
l'exercice de votre de fonction j'essaie
de faire en sorte que ça ne change pas
mais c'est vrai qu'on se rend compte que
sur les réseaux sociaux
n'importe qui peut balancer n'importe
quoi excusez moi du terme mais des fois
je le ressens comme ça et puis bah si on
veut passer derrière enfin on pourrait
passer ses journées à essayer de
répondre
voilà donc c'est ce qui me gêne dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est qu'en fait on peut
poster une information qui est faux et
donc si on n'est pas en veille
systématique et c est bien cette
information se diffuse et donc ça a été
vraiment quelque chose que j'ai vécu des
heures pendant les élections dans la
campagne électorale s'était beaucoup et
là c'était un super jeu mais c'est donc
c'est très bel hiver avec des attaques
qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire qu'on diffuse
une information qui a l'air d'être réel
et puis après ça fait boule de neige
puisque tout le monde s'entend pas juste
moi je j'ai lu le j'ai lu le livre de
nicole basaran sur le monde selon trump
où elle fait ou est elle prend tous ces
tweets par par thématique
c'est absolument étonnant étonnant pour
pas dire à teyran aussi d'ailleurs parce
que justement on balance balance des
informations voilà et puis personne ne
peut aller les contredire les vérifier
et voilà donc ça c'est tout le danger
des réseaux sociaux parce que les gens
peuvent se limiter la teste beaucoup il
a gouverné par twitter
aux dons sur les réseaux sociaux je
pense que c'est le les réseaux sociaux
ils ont ils ont une vertu parce
qu'effectivement ça permet de donner de
l'information jean enfin au plus grand
nombre puisque beaucoup de gens foncent
en emparent mais le mais la difficulté
c'est de ne pas pouvoir démentir à
chaque fois tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est raconté lors mazaury au fond trump
c'est la figure ou le symbole du
populisme ce qu'on appelle le populisme
oui certainement certainement je vais
réagir car alors bien entendu c'est un
populiste et donc par conséquent encore
que dans populiste jeudi au nom du
peuple alors que personne ne sait ce
qu'est le peuple voilà si en plus c'est
un peuple revisité évidemment évidemment
retranscrit par rapport à ces proposer
des noms mais sur la partie qui concerne
trump et l'usagé réseaux sociaux je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux
non de sociaux que le nom ce ne sont pas
des réseaux sociaux ce ne sera
certainement pas un lieu où il faut
interagir avec autrui
par conséquent on joue toujours en
défense quand au jour défense on n'est
pas mon communication on doit jouer en
communication descendante si on commence
comme le disait man city à discuter sur
les réseaux sociaux à répondre à tout ce
qui s'y trouve d'abord c'est voilà c'est
l'histoire c'est l'histoire sans fin
beaucoup et puis beaucoup d'informations
ils sont fins beaucoup d'informations
évidemment ne servent qu à désinformer
ou à manipuler
donc pour moi ça reste un vecteur de
transmission d'informations mais
certainement pas un lieu où on peut
débattre et on peut argumenter d'abord
parce que ces débats trémie à la
vindicte populaire
son grand intérêt et sans grande
efficacité ses premiers points et tout
cela pour moi tourne autour du même
sujet que je suis la démocratie c'est
celui de l'éducation
c'est à dire qu'il faut apprendre aux
enfants dès le plus jeune âge à savoir
utiliser les réseaux sociaux à savoir
les prendre comme pour ce qu'ils sont et
pas pour autre chose est de même pour ce
qui concerne la démocratie ce qu'on a pu
voir aux états unis de toujours
considéré aussi que être en démocratie
c'est faire un effort individuel c'est
celui de se plier à la majorité c'est
pas celui de l'individu c'est l'individu
c'est l'intérêt général qui prime sur
l'intérêt individuel et par conséquent
comme dans un réseau social je dois
reconnaître qu'il ya la victoire d'un
opposant parce que la majorité s'est
exprimée ce qui est loin d'être facile
pour l'être humain qui est certes un
animal social c'est très difficile
d'oublier la majorité et là on est dans
notre rôle en tant qu'élu de s'assurer
que tout ce qui touche à l'éducation des
enfants renom et
donc conclure met à disposition des
écoles des bâtiments mais pour la partie
des élus nationaux qui doivent avoir une
politique d'éducation forte
le premier rôle ou le deuxième rôle de
la démocratie c'est de savoir apprendre
aux enfants à des républicains
la république c'est effectivement
j'entends tout le monde j'ai le droit de
l'exprimer mais à un moment donné une
élection a lieu et c'est compliqué
individus peuvent se plier au vote
majoritaire et tout ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est sur le réseau
social je conteste la décision
majoritaire aux états unis je prends
alors évidemment je croyais de non droit
mais encore une fois la façon de
contester justement une élection belle
c'est ce qu'avait fait des confédérés de
ligue 1 c'est d'aller devant le juge de
juges les déboute à un moment donné ça
s'arrête et la france pour cela à ce
jour en tout cas est exemplaire et je
terminerai sur ce point pour que tout
cela fonctionne il faut évidemment un
bras armé de la démocratie parce qu'à un
moment donné quand on viole les règles
doit être sanctionné ce bras armé c'est
la justice et la police et monsieur
trump relève à ce titre-là de cette
procédure la com sur les réseaux sociaux
demain si demain n'importe qui vient
dire n'importe quoi sur les élus ou sur
n'importe quel autre citoyen il doit
être poursuivi et la responsabilité de
l'hébergeur et je rejoins ce qui a été
dit elle est totale c'est pas parce que
oui d'ailleurs je vais faire des raids
suis aussi on sent bien que le
revirement est très récent de la part de
tous du même google twitter facebook
pourquoi parce que voyant arriver
effectivement un président démocrate et
sachant que dans les cartons de joe
biden ya la volonté un petit peu aussi
de découper une partie de l'actionnariat
de ses différents réseaux sociaux
ce qu'a fait la chine avec des moyens
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus direct en lice
à faire ils font disparaître les
présidences éveiller les efficace l'unc
a disparu tout comme facebook twitter et
instagram deviennent des modérateurs en
disant mon dieu que va-t-il m'arriver je
vais donner l'exemple
ce qui d'ailleurs est vous avez raison
mais quelque part ne fait que les les
plonger encore plus dans une forme de
responsables ce que en montrant
l'exemple de modération ils vont très
bien effectivement que ce sont des
éditeurs et non plus des berges
donc ils vont tomber certainement
beaucoup de très mauvaises surprises de
ce qui arrive dès ce que j'espère bien
que monsieur baden mettra en place et
enfoncé un projet de loi pour t pain
eric dupond-moretti alors qu'il essaye
justement de savoir qui doit décider de
savoir si quelqu'un doit sanctionner
quand quand la haine ou les des propos
racistes etc sont proférées sur des
réseaux sociaux
juste un mot pour terminer parce que je
voudrais qu'on passe maintenant à la
vaccination et me porter je pense que
vous attendez le 20 janvier avec
impatience mais c'est quand même une
amérique morcelé que va avoir à
gouverner joe biden avait du pain sur la
planche s'occupait du convient de
relancer l'économie
relancer les accords sur le climat
s'attaquer à l'injustice raciale j'en
passe et des meilleurs et maintenant il
est juste à rétablir la démocratie donc
oui c'est vrai que ça ne va pas lui
faciliter la tâche
mais j'aimerais terminer avec deux mots
un sur twitter tout le monde pense que
twitter est une espace public peter est
une entreprise privée petter à des
règles qu'on ne peut pas mentir et qu'on
ne peut pas inciter à la violence sur
son réseau trump n'a pas suivi les
règles ils étaient dégagés ça n'a rien à
voir avec la parole la liberté parole ni
le premier amendement
on a fait le parallèle avec caen après
que la loi sur le mariage gay a été
adopté vous avez des tas de boulangerie
qui ont refusé de faire des gâteaux de
mariage pour des couples gays en disant
je suis jeune entreprise privée je fais
les règles je fais ce que je veux
là dans ce cas la future c'est la
boulangerie et tom c'est le gâteau
donc il faut pas qu'il se baigne
maintenant il qu'il est écarté de ce
réseau là et pour terminer je dirai
juste que si vous regardez bien les
images qui sont en train de sortir la
maintenant dans les derniers jours et
les les déclarations des centaines
d'émeutiers qui ont déjà été arrêtés je
pense que les gens ne mesurent pas qu'il
y avait parmi ce groupe là des gens qui
sont venus pour assassiner des
dirigeants
il avait des menottes qu'ils voulaient
prendre les otages ils étaient 1 mais
ils ont placé deux bombes et leurs
déclarations sont absolument glaçante
donc on était à quelques minutes voire
quelques secondes
d'un bain de sang non pas seulement de
toute la ligne de succession des états
unis peines pelosi glace lee qui était
tous dans le même immeuble
mais des centaines de législateurs qui
étaient cachées sur le chien leurs
chaises donc de finir emploi cet assaut
ce n'était pas juste un tas d'idiots qui
ont mis leur nom et leur leur endroit
sur les réseaux sociaux permettant au
fbi avait récolté 48 heures après ce qui
est en train de se passer
mais il y avait vraiment un désir de
faire de faire dix crus psion et de
change des échanges et le pouvoir
je sais pas si c'est la définition d'un
coup d'état mais en tout cas c'est
hirson de doha doit être puni et ils le
seront et tous ceux qui les ont incités
en l'aimant temps en leur donnant leur
alimentant avec des mensonges depuis des
mois pourquoi on me disait jean batut
faire quoi les gens croient que
l'élection a volé a été volé parce que
30 n'arrête pas de leur dire donc cette
notion il ya des allégations mais c'est
lui qui donne les allégations dont il
peut pas maintenant dire à moi j'ai rien
dit il le dit depuis des mois et il en
est capable
ok on va vendre alors là le jeu ce
chapitre américain mais qui concerne
évidemment tout le monde c'est pour ça
que vous souhaitez en parler et on va on
va aborder cette la deuxième question de
cette émission c'est à dire la
vaccination est un peu le grand foutoir
qu'on a vu en france alors on pourrait
citer un certain nombre de médecins
professeurs et axel kahn parle d'un
désastre de réactivation le docteur
bourdillon qu'il fondateur de santé
publique explique nous souffrons de
procédures trop lourdes et trop complexe
et d'une communication anxiogène en tout
cas ça on a vu que la machine après du
retard des dettes dès le départ vous
faites partie des 200 maires qui ont
signé une pétition pour montrer que vous
biais vous désirez vous faire vacciner
pourquoi pourquoi cette démarche
alexandre city alors c'est là la
démarche qui a entrepris donc génération
terrain sous la houlette de karl olive
le maire de poissy
l'idée derrière ça c'est surtout pas de
passer devant tout le monde pour se
faire vacciner évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs on a cru comprendre que les
ministres ou de président de la
république n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner de peur qu'on les accuse de
passer avant tout le monde
alors que il aurait peut-être pu donner
l'exemple pour finir on se dit mais
alors du coup ça peut alimenter l'idée
c'est de dire aux gens qui sont
sceptiques qu'il faut y aller
voilà c'est plutôt à valeur d'exemple
parce que les élus de terrain ils sont
là depuis le début
je pense que la péta n'ayons pas peur la
première crise on était là on a géré
énormément de choses dont les masques
étaient même été un épisode assez assez
remarquable
donc là l'idée c'est vraiment bien bas
nous on nous on se fera vacciner et on
veut bien montrer l'exemple
je pense qu'il faut pas que les maires
soient mis les premiers vaccinés mais
qu'ils soient dans la masse des gens qui
vont qui vont y aller ne serait ce que
pour pour ça pour dire que ce geste
citoyennes et citoyens qui font il faut
qu'on sorte de cette crise et donc 600
n'avait pas de vaccin oral ray parce
qu'on en a pas on en a et maintenant on
commence à dire ah oui mais non mais
peut-être que c'est pas bien et c'est
donc moi je pense qu'il faut il faut y
aller maintenant moi je vais vous dire
depuis le début de cette crise je suis
de ceux qui est je suis très prudent
dans mes commentaires parce que je me
dis j'aimerais tout le monde vit
d'ailleurs on n'aimerait pas être à leur
place non non non seulement on a
c'est vrai qu'on se dit c'est une crise
sans précédent donc c'est extrêmement
complet on a frisé les jours en plus on
finit un pays m lemaitre dans un état
économique enfin comme tous les autres
pays d'ailleurs donc je depuis le début
je me garde de critiquer parce que je me
dis on sait que milla vous le dis quand
même cette vaccination on sait qu'on
savait qu'elle allait arriver on
l'attend depuis longtemps
là j'avoue je vais plutôt dans le sens
là cette faute dire mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bazar parce que oui nous on
est prêts on est prêt à aider on est
prêts on est prêt à monter des centres
de vaccination dans nos communes alors
saint quentin en yvelines a appris un
petit peu le lead sur le sujet justement
parce qu'elle est en contact avec la rs
et c'est très bien donc les 12 communes
attendent le doigt sur la couture du
pantalon qu'on dise bon ok vous pouvez
démarrer président voici là évidemment
vers ça l'a déjà vrai bon ce sont des
grandes communes donc les communes
n'auront peut-être pas les mêmes moyens
parce que ça pose aussi des ça pose
aussi des questions en termes de locaux
à mettre à disposition sur la durée de
trouver aussi des médecins des
pharmaciens fin des personnes qui
veulent bien venir pas donné de leur
temps pour vacciner parce que quand vous
avez des doses de ce que j'ai compris en
cinq jours faut qu'elle soit utilisé
sinon tout cas elle adopta aussi des
contraintes techniques mais je veux dire
les maires ils ont toujours été là et
ils seront encore là
maintenant c'est vrai que on attend sur
les procédures mais c'est pas une
nouveauté les procédures en france je me
souviens d'avoir entendu parler ce
volant du choc de simplification excusez
moi je l'attends encore c'est juste
hallucinant ce qu'on vit dans ce pays en
terme de procédure de class est juste au
fait à un exemple de ce qu'on veut faire
pour que ce que je peux vous dire qu'on
pour lève pas le petit doigt sans avoir
mis en place des procédures l'euro
mazauric d'attaché en colère la double
ou en fait - éboué littéralement moi je
suis fou furieux en fait alors je fais
aussi partie des 200 qui ont signé la
pire dont je suis fou furieux
effectivement quand emmanuel macron a
été élu même si je n'ai pas soutenu
je me suis dit on à la peut-être la
chance d'avoir quelqu'un qui va importer
dans la sphère publique ce qu'on fait
dans le privé en termes d'efficacité
allez j'ai effectivement les procédures
mais même avoir une forme de prise de
conscience de l'ensemble des services
on peut pas nous dit
en matière de vaccins que l'on ne savait
pas qu à un moment donné on aurait à
vaccin peu importe quand on savait qu'on
allait la voir s'en rappelle plus dans
cinq ans il s'en était une catastrophe
ne peut pas attendre que le vaccin
arrive pour tout d'un coup se dire
comment on va faire la logistique qui va
piquer on va utiliser 5 12 6 dose on va
comment on va faire pour le conserver
enfin ça fait des mois mais ça fait des
mois qu'on sait que le vaccin arrivera
donc en privé on travaille toujours sur
une notion de rétro planning
alors je sais que c'est facile ici là de
dire il de faire du yaka fokon il y
avait qu à il faudrait que mais enfin
voilà trois fois de suite que l'on fait
la même chose
la première phase avec sunrise en a
parlé les masques alors il ya eu une
décision politique laïque ce temps je
veux pas y revenir très dur à faire des
économies sur les masses à rennes en
stocker autant balzar dont le stock en
commande et moins bon très bien donc
première erreur mais quand monsieur le
phénomène arrive on est combien de temps
avant de relancer les commandes de
masques
puis ensuite les tests c'est le même
sens nous a joué la même chose sur le
test alors je viens à l'essai deux et
hop a eu deux épisodes là c'était
compliqué mais pendant tout ce temps là
on savait que les gens trail sur les
vaccins je prends les cas l'exemple d'un
état qu'on cite aujourd'hui parce que il
me semble être le plus en avance
israël il a qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait à
israël ils ont commandé en avant des
vaccins à revenir oui ils l'ont payé
deux fois plus cher mais la vie n'a pas
de prix et le deux fois plus cher sur
les vaccins est sans commune mesure avec
les efforts que l'on va faire pour
sauver je l'espère et que l'on fait déjà
pour son annexion en entreprise qui sont
d'ailleurs à mettre en exergue la france
est vraiment à des pays du monde qui
sous la houlette de monsieur matte ont
fait le plus d'efforts pour maintenir à
flot coûte que coûte
nos entreprises mais une partie de cet
effort pour avoir être conférés sur le
fait de commander des vaccins en avant
de prendre ce pari là ce pari là n'a pas
été fait ce pour des raisons que je suis
désolé qu'ils sont économiques voire
même voire même et je veux pas rentrer
en compétition voire même avec une
vision qui est de dire on va plutôt
favoriser tel type de vaccin parce qu'il
est un peu plus européen voire un peu
plus français que tel au départ on a
essayé de favoriser sanofi oui je
voulais pas donner un autre chez nous on
peut le donner
il ya une technique de classiques de
vaccins c'est à dire qu'on a notre ville
peur de virus ce qui n'est pas le leur
aide messager de pfizer a besoin de
modern art alors moi je suis le fou
furieux de cette réunion se déterminer
sur ce point là et ensuite la partie
vacciner concrètement au jour le jour
qu'est ce que je vois en israël une
multiplication des centres ces mêmes que
vous avez des chiffres le 4 janvier
dernier il y avait un million de
vaccinés en israël et 2000 en france
voilà voilà aujourd'hui à l'assemblée ce
matin pour la france je ne sais pas
quand l'émission repassera et on nous
annonce qu'il serait d'avoir un phénix
vacciner la totalité de sa population la
totalité de sa population
fin mars le regardera où nous en serons
nous mais mais mais c'est des choses de
bon sens
vous savez quand israël vous pouvez vous
faire exceller en voiture c'est là que
vous arrivez que votre véhicule
c'est le mcdrive voilà c'est le drive je
m'assois on vaccine dans l'épaule je
repars on se vaccine des sablons avec sa
carte d'identité
mais je vais volontaires quoi mais bien
sûr mais alors et attention je pourrais
aller aussi sur le sujet comme ça mes
amis vont tous me taper dessus à bras
raccourcis
je ne comprends même pas que la
vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
allez jouer le général
quand je viens là mais sur des zones
économiques sont à 9 ans mais
aujourd'hui je sais n'at-il donc de
vaccin parce que malheureusement j'ai le
physique est grande c'est bien entendu
la vacciner je sais plus combien de
vaccins obligatoires 9 12 13 je ne sais
plus ce soir soit ce vaccin est sans
risque et a semblé leur est dû est
obligatoire soit il ya des risques
auxquels on nous le dit pas lorsqu'on
veut pas être subi la responsabilité
très bien et on ne rend pas obligatoire
mais ce n'est pas une raison de ne pas
aller au terme de l'organisation de
cette vaccination dans un délai
acceptable
je rappelle que des gens meurent moi
j'ai perdu mon père au mois de mars
cette maladie je je considérerai comme
une forme de crime de ne pas faire le
maximum dans les plus vite possible et
je termine là dessus de prison nous a
dit on est en guerre il l'a répété je ne
sais combien de fois quand on est en
guerre au moment où on prend des canons
et qu'on doit tirer sur l'ennemi
on n'est pas en train de se poser la
problématique de la procédure
administrative pour savoir si une canon
il est conforme s'il a bien été livrés
six matches à lille a certes fait ça je
caricature on tire on est en guerre ça
s'appelle esprit d'initiative
individuelle des acteurs
si l'on ne gagne pas une guerre on
serait le débarquement des lieux dix ans
plus tard pardon ajm
ce qu'en dit ou fait d'histoire et
certains historiens de 10,1 et c'est
intéressant disent au fond
l'angleterre l'allemagne ils ont fait la
guerre la deuxième guerre mondiale nous
on a collaboré pendant quatre ans donc
on s'est peut-être pas faire une
économie de guerre à tous dire juste un
mot effectivement à ce sujet avec la
france n'a pas forcément une économie
une économie en berne de guerre ni même
une administration prête pour ça en fait
si je peux juste faire référence à
quelque chose de très ennuyeux pour les
auditeurs mais qui est-elle un rapport
de la cour des comptes de novembre 2020
dans laquelle la cour des comptes nous
dit que la france est là 93000
administration contrairement à 15000
pour l'allemand l'allemagne alors que
l'allemagne est un état fédéral
c'est à dire qu'il fonctionne à double
niveau et donc on a souvent critiqué les
doublons en allemagne résultat vous
voyez le nombre en france
la cour des comptes a dit clairement
dans son rapport peu ses 93 milles
entité administrative 1 qui existent en
france ne permettent pas de flécher des
décisions et les moyens en fonction des
priorités politiques
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans ce
rapport de la cour des comptes et c'est
ce que dans le sens de ce que disait
laurent et à leur dire c'est ce qui fait
que en fait on n'est pas en mesure
d'avoir la flexibilité et la prise de
décisions suffisante pour eux pour faire
face à cette épidémie
rappelez moi le chiffre de structures
administratives 93000 en france qu'entre
15 mille ans en allemagne
jean baptiste duterte justement que vous
êtes spécialiste de droit public
cette bureaucratie cette accumulation de
d'autorisation de précaution est ce que
vous pensez qu'elle est réelle et
qu'elle était peut-être nécessaire j'en
sais rien d'ailleurs
oui je crois qu'il faut peut-être pas il
a géré le toux des maux à
l'administration française sont
parfaitement réel
là je crois tout simplement en perte au
niveau décisionnel le prix de la
république s'est surtout appuyé sur le
conseil scientifique qui donc
à donner ses conseils très avisés sur la
tactique à suivre par rapport au vaccin
mais est d'ailleurs en trop long et demi
il n'y avait pas de personnes
compétentes en logistique au sein de ce
conseil est donc je crois que tout
simplement l'erreur vient de là elle
vient tout simplement que l'état ne
s'est pas n'a pas justement mobilisés
parmi les nombreux services dont ils
disposent à supposer même qu'il est là
qu'il est les autorités compétentes les
personnes justement pour m faire faire
les bons choix
donc je crois en fait le problème était
assez simple finalement à ce matin nous
avons reçu deux fois cinq cent mille
doses nous avons été livrés d'un million
de doses nous avons vacciné
cent mille personnes voilà juste je
désire jouer nous c'est créer un comité
comment être un citoyen qui vont nous
expliquer d'être conseillés par ailleurs
ce furent à des privés on nous a fait la
convention citoyenne sur le climat ray
est maintenant à 35 nom de quoi ces 35
personnes nous représente t-il les
seules personnes du clan désolé
évidemment les élus représentent le
peuple nous mais surtout les autres
enfin c'est quand même là on revient sur
le sujet de la démocratie alors c'est un
gadget de communication je comprends
bien l'opération c'est une forme de
déresponsabilisation ça donne
l'impression d'une nouvelle fois d'être
dans ce cas plaît ségolène royal la
démocratie participative mais non moi je
ne suis pas bon démocratie perspective
je suis pour une république
merci france 348 sénateurs 577 députés
1760 conseillers régionaux quatre mille
conseillers départementaux 35000 mère
520 mille conseillers municipaux
est ce qu'on a besoin de 35 personnes
encore et encore c'est pas le nombre de
ces zahia qui me semble le plus choquant
c'est le nombre d administration dont on
a parlé donc d administration
est ce que est ce que l'on est on est
vraiment un carnage honni est ce que
c'est vraiment le mal français qui se
développe dans cette campagne de
vaccination bah oui oui je crois qu'on
met vraiment la quintessence de
l'absurdité c'est à dire que le discours
du du gouvernement est absolument
incompréhensible et est totalement
incohérent
juste un exemple ce vaccin on a tous les
pharmaciens qui vaccinent à tour de bras
qui vacciner à l'aîné dernier à tour de
bras contre la grippe
ils savent planter une une une seringue
dans un bras et il n'y a pas de problème
et là on le dit annonce du pharmacien ne
peuvent pas le faire parce qu'il faut
absolument un médecin à chaque fois
qu'on vaccine quelqu'un c'est à dire que
pour rendre les gens anxieux ya pas
mieux taire que le vaccin est soi-disant
parfait et machin mais ils font un max
ils font un médecin pour surveiller qui
aurait pas quelque chose mais on est
juste dans le n'importe quoi comme le
disait jean soit le vaccin est bon et on
vaccine soit il est pas bon et on fait
attention mais on arrête de faire ça les
possibilités de vaccins et sont de
vaccination et sont énormes les
formations ne demande qu'une chose c'est
de s'y coller et non on leur interdit de
faire
donc voilà donc dans tous les autres
pays ça se passe bien en france ça fasse
mal
mais pourquoi parce que systématiquement
il ya cette trouille des politiques elle
reconnaître que les deux élus ici
présents pour nous en parler mais mais
il ya dix blancs secs rentes pénale à
chaque fois qu'il ya une décision qui
est prise
quai de gare ou là attention si on fait
ça on va on va nous faire des procès on
va nous traîner en justice etc
c'est absolument terry et ça c'est
absolument monstrueux comme que comme il
est alors il faut arrêter avec ça et
puis en plus là où moi j'en veux
terriblement mâcon mais ça dépasse le
simple choc des vaccinations et moi
al'inverse de l'orangé côté macro et je
ne le regrettaient pas jusqu'à il ya peu
mais franchement je veux dire gouverner
un moment on peut dire que c est prendre
des décisions impopulaires
lui ne prend pas les décisions et va
finir impopulaires alors franchement on
se dit mais quelqu'un quel gâchis quel
gâchis c'est à dire qu il n'y a pas de
courage politique
et puis on a emmené à castex halak ce
qui à part animé un théâtre une fois par
semaine les besoins masquer leur tire
mon masque etc vous demander juste là
l'absurdité gouvernementales et
permanente permanent donc on ira georgia
qui avait prêté macron au premier tour
avant de vous laisser la parole jeudi
et me porte les etats unis sont passés
en tête en fin d'épisode de vaccination
vous avez je suppose des amis qui ont
déjà été vaccinées raconter les choses
simplement est ce que est ce que y est
vous avez bon d'effets secondaires de
choses qui se remet le passé ou pas
alors c'est fascinant cette conversation
parce qu'on est en train de se plaindre
du fait que en france tout est
centralisé la bureaucratie et et lourdes
etc
les etats-unis ont fait le contraire ils
ont dit aux 50 états tenez voici le
vaccin débrouillez vous donc il y à 50
l'an différents et même à l'intérieur
d'un étage que vous parlez de l'état
brut parce que c'est de là que vient
chaque côté créé sa propre politique
donc si vous êtes à miami ou fait
vacciner dans leur est si vous vous êtes
dans leurs comptes et juste après huit
là où habite masters il faut prendre
rendez vous alors vous essayez d'appeler
pour prendre rendez-vous vous n'arrivez
pas à joindre des gens donc mon beau
frère s'est fait vacciner mercredi
garmin avait un vent des goûts il a
attendu d'enfants dans sa voiture pour
le drive il entendu quatre heures et
demie en ayant un rendez vous ma soeur
est censé se faire vacciner mais recule
donc un vrai comment ça se passe alors
qu'à miami
vous n'avez pas besoin de prendre rendez
vous vous appelez présenter ce cas donc
c'est une cacophonie c'est une pagaille
ce temps n'ont donc quelque part je vis
centralisée au niveau fédéral serait ça
pourrait pas être client mais c'est vrai
que moi ça fait 34 ans que je suis en
france
la bureaucratie française quand j'ai
demandé ma n'a sauté française ça on
pourrait faire toute une émission du sud
combien de nessma fring c'est vrai que
quand il entendu parlé qu'il fallait
attendre quatre jours après avoir
mais sans accord après avoir sans
médecin et je me suis dit mais on
hallucine en est tombé sur la tête
moi je me fais vacciner demain vous avez
vu vers la pharmacie jeu tend le bras
terminé donc c'est vrai que entre les
deux systèmes je sais pas peut-être
d'israël où la dengue fait les gens qui
en fait c'est mieux moi je me souviens à
l'époque de la chaîne alain je suis allé
à saint germain en laye vous avez
transformé un gymnase enfin de
vaccination y avait pas de rendez vous
on s'est présenté avec mon découvert
deux enfants à l'époque il était petit
on s'est fait vacciner ça s'est très
bien passé
je ne comprends pas pourquoi avec
l'expérience passée en hésitant à mettre
en place un système qui fonctionne juste
juste qu'en ma qualité de fac et coeur
je suis obligée d'intervenir mais émis
émis le délai de quatre jours avant de
vacciner sas et c'est pas une
information qui a circulé mais qui est
complètement fausse
une fois que maintenant il n'y a pas de
délai de rétractation quoi que ce soit
très bien plein de problèmes il ya peu
notre problème
celui-là ont heureusement sont autant
éviter les faux problème et qu'elle est
choquée est ce que justement existe dans
les ehpad et seulement dans les ehpad
quand on demande à une personne âgée si
elle veut se faire vacciner
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
bien qu'ils sont les poteaux des gens
qui sont supposés ce qu'on appelle des
sachants et qu'on est déjà trop avoir
trois informations différentes ça prouve
bien que la problématique aussi de
l'information aller catastrophique ces
sujets là la preuve
la preuve florence bariseau qu'il est ce
que le le au fond cette centralisation
française c'est pas ça le problème
évidemment je n'arrive pas à comprendre
enfin je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
laurent basauri et avec jean-charles
comme une fois
je n'arrive pas à comprendre et pas la
possibilité je crois qu'en toute ville
il ya salle des fêtes
je comprends pas livre pas et vaccins à
la mairie ou directement dans ces
centres lent et qu'on laisse les merdes
façon tout le monde a la même
information c'est pas comme aux états
unis où chacun dans chaque état dans
chaque poupée par sa propre procédure
là c'est une procédure équivalente sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
et après c'est un problème
d'organisation et effectivement cette
centralisation surplus qui a été mais je
suis je suis scandalisé par la façon
dont ça s'est passé sur ce monde de
logistique seulement d'anticipation on a
l'impression qu'ils sont complètement
aveugle tétanisé j'en sais rien mais je
ne comprends pas du tout ce retard
cette absence de collaboration avec les
départements où avec directement les
mairies je pense que si on avait fait ça
il y avait déjà une centaine de milliers
de personnes ont été vaccinées dans
chaque sens organisation et l'absence de
communication et coopération est
affligeante
justement je l'envoie à une interview
que j'ai fait qui est sur le site de tv
70 du docteur lehmann qui est écrivain
qui est médecin à poissy qui a annoncé
justement ces centres et il dit au fond
il ya une impéritie de l'état il ya une
incapacité de l'est pas donc ben nous on
va faire c'est aux mairies de fait est
ce que vous vous sentez alexandre ces
types peut-être une responsabilité plus
grande
il faut à nos moments agir il faut
prendre la place de l'état si l'état est
incompétent ou incapable de mettre en
place les procédures jeudi tour med sur
les mairies ça me semble quand même un
petit peu facile je pense qu'il faut
qu'il ya un travail partenarial entre
l'état et la mairie
parce que
voilà parce qu'il ya c'est quand même
bon il ya quand même des procédures et
c'était bien qu'ils en aient aussi sur
la mise à disposition de salles de
gymnases etc
nous aussi on a on a aussi une autre
problématique dont ça dépend combien de
temps dans les meilleures dispositions
parce que nous on accueille aussi des
associations qui sont en train de
reprendre doucement avec les des enfants
qui ont beaucoup aussi souffert de cet
enfermement
donc il faut aussi nous qu'on arrive à
gérer ça c'est à dire à qui on comment
conjuguer l'accueil la vaccination tout
en permettant à nos associations de
continuer à vivre et de faire des choses
pour les enfants au cas il ya c'est dans
le domaine très très pratique tu voyais
c'est ça peut paraître simple mais il ya
quand même ce sujet là après moi je suis
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
ce serait ce qu'il faudra et mais j'ai
besoin de l'état quand même je peux pas
le faire sans lui parce que les parce
que les vaccins doivent être conservés à
une certaine température
alors c'est vrai qu'en plus ils ont mis
des registres en place donc si on
vaccine il faut remplir le registre et g
ça demande de la logistique ans quand
même après je pense que les élus l'ont
très vite j'ai lancé un pavé dans la
mare moi je vous propose une chose très
simple je vous propose de remplacer
olivier ferrand par roselyne bachelot et
de m olivier ferrand la culture parce
que la finale robin tout le monde s'est
moqué d'elle rappelez-vous parce qu'on
avait dépensé des millions parce qu'on
avait commandé des doses pour acheter je
rencontre aux îles bachelot pour ce
genre d'opération parce qu'en vérité ce
n'est pas une opération médicale dont on
parle c'est une opération logistique et
financière logistique c'est pour ça que
tu as raison on peut s'arranger pour le
faire voilà celui travail dont on peut
le faire et que l'autre aspect c'est
juste encore une fois amené un nombre
suffisant de vaccins au bon endroit pour
piquer des gens
nous n'allons pas chercher autre chose
d'autant car il leva rien
anglais et qui va sans doute nous avons
nous nous obliger à être encore plus
rapide dans cette vaccination
un dernier mot chacun parce qu il faut
qu on se quitte d'urgence aux banques je
voulais juste dire à laurent qu'on n'est
pas obligé de recaser olivier verrons si
on enlève ministre de la junte est
retourné dans son cabinet et repartir se
laver les mains toutes les trois minutes
comme il adore le faire et voilà le
gouvernement ne vacillera pas sur ces
bases
un dernier mot peut-être jean baptiste
du quai au four est ce cas là il va y
avoir probablement des conséquences
politiques de cette gestion de la classe
du coc vide est ce qui est manuel masque
où on va pas avoir l'image au fond du
stade war c'est à dire pendant son credo
qaîda il craint pas marine beaucoup
beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles
je pense que souffrance oui mais c'est
dommage j'ai besoin qu'on est là pour
réveiller les hommes d'état c'est dans
ces moments là justement vrai on peut
arriver à briller et je crois que ce qui
est dommage c'est que justement sur ce
sujet très précis manuel mâcon a
critiqué son administration au même
ministère en disant qu'il y avait une
lenteur injustifiée alors qu'on sait
parfaitement qu'en période est
majoritaire si le reste c'est le
président de la république qui prend
toutes les grandes décisions et qu'il
n'a pas souhaité assumer je pense pas
que ça va aider justement à arreux
légitimité apologie légitimée par des
actions politiques voilà vous voyez mais
portant ya pas qu aux etats-unis que le
problème se pose merci à tous merci alex
burrows et si merci laurent mazaury
merci franz mack à des shows qui me
porte
jean baptiste duclair vincent couronne
et jean-charles la jolie et à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
profs
[Musique]